das hier ist keine normale hilfsaktion
sondern propaganda in eigener sache
das kartell alice cooper generation
liefert aus klopapier und lebensmittel
und lässt dabei die kamera laufen die
bilder verbreiten sich über soziale
medien zehntausendfach im land
ein mensch ist der chef des kartells und
der meistgesuchte mann mexikos ein
verbrecher der den wohltäter gibt die
bilder zeigen ist längst sind die
kartelle staat im staate wir sind in
guadalajara der hauptstadt des
bundesstaates rallyes co entführungen
folter mord gehören zum alltag
auch hier haben die kartelle
lebensmittel verteilt in einem land in
dem jeder zweite unterhalb der
armutsgrenze lebt kommt das an
das wissen sie auch bei der
hilfsorganisation tattoo alessandra und
ihre kollegen sind seit jahren vor ort
lange vor den kadetten eigentlich bauen
sie hätten doch jetzt brauchen die
menschen vor allem etwas zu essen
momentan verteilen wir hier wegen der
pandemie lebensmittel
das ist jetzt die zweite lieferung die
wir machen die erste war im mai jetzt
ist ja schon juli und wir geben die
zweite runde an 62 familien die am
stärksten von der pandemie betroffen
sind die meisten hier sind tagelöhner
durch corona haben fast alle ihre jobs
verloren hilfe vom staat bekommt hier
kaum jemand bohnenkaffee und dann haben
wir da noch cornflakes und thunfisch
umso wichtiger sind die pakete von
catcher mit grundnahrungsmitteln die
ihnen in den nächsten wochen über die
runden helfen
alles was man zu hause so braucht corona
hat mexiko hart getroffen
40.000 tote gibt es im land die
dunkelziffer ist wohl höher
beatrice traut sich deswegen erst gar
nicht aus der hütte nun es ist schon
eine hilfe
momentan wo so viele menschen ohne
arbeit dastehen
da hilft es schon von den aktionen der
catella hat sie gehört sie selbst hat
keines der pakete bekommen sagt sie
er ist egal wer sie unterstützt ja das
ist okay sie helfen uns sie helfen uns
eben wo sie können
kartelle als vermeintliche helfer in der
not auch mitglieder des berüchtigten
sinaloa kartells lassen sich dabei
filmen wie sie lebensmittel spenden
zusammen stellen
ihr ehemaliger boss el chapo sitzt in
den usa im gefängnis sein konterfei
ziert jede tüte damit auch jeder weiß
von wem die spende kommt
gerade in diesen zeiten brauchen die
leute uns nakos mehr als zuvor von der
regierung bekommen sie ja keine hilfe
die journalistin maria italia gomez
beschäftigt sich seit jahren mit den
kartellen den narcos es ist kein zufall
erzählt sie uns dass sie während corona
aktiv werden
es ist eine botschaft für ihre feinde
für die regierung aber es ist auch eine
botschaft für die eigenen verbündeten
ist ein bisschen wie das aufstellen
einer flagge auf dem mond sie verteilen
lebensmittel in diesen gemeinden und zu
zeigen dass sie ihnen gehören der
mexikanische staat hat dem wenig
entgegenzusetzen
das war es wohl auch der präsident als
er auf die catella angesprochen wird
ich nutze diese gelegenheit um
denjenigen die in kriminellen
organisationen sind zu sagen dass ich
gesehen habe wie sie lebensmittel
verteilen
das hilft nicht weiter
das klingt wie hohn in einem land in dem
täglich 100 menschen ermordet werden
indem der staat sich schießereien mit
den narcos liefert und oft hilflos
aufgeben muss so wie im oktober 2009 10
als ein sohn von el chapo von kartellen
mitgliedern aus den händen der polizei
befreit wird
und der präsident lässt ein paar monate
später seine wagenkolonne anhalten um
einer alten frau die hand zu schütteln
es ist die mutter von el chapo man
manchmal muss ich händeschütteln das ist
mein job mit respektierten
geschäftsleute die eigentlich kriminelle
wie kann ich also einer dame nicht die
hand schütteln wie kann sich ihre
ausgestreckte hand einfach ignorieren
was ist falsch daran was ist richtig was
ist falsch es ist eine frage die das
land beschäftigt nicht erst seitdem die
regierung offiziell einen krieg gegen
die drogenkartelle führt seit 2006
gewalt korruption angst sie sind überall
spürbar
auch im zentrum von guadalajara wo wir
natalio treffen dem wegen corona an
seinem imbiss stand die kunden fehlen
im endeffekt anzumerken ist
wirtschaftlich auf jeden fall die
menschen kaufen nichts und sie können
auf anordnung der regierung nicht
arbeiten
das macht uns allen sorgen jetzt macht
der privat auch noch umzüge irgendwo
muss das geld ja herkommen denn
staatliche unterstützung bekommt er
nicht nein er kämpft jeder für sich die
regierung hilft nicht nebenan muss auch
rossi kämpfen er putzt schuhe obwohl er
eigentlich rentner ist gerade hat er
5000 pesos umgerechnet 200 euro rente
bekommen für vier monate
die regierung könnte mehr tun
es gibt einfach vieles wo sie es
unterlassen haben zu handeln eigentlich
denkt die regierung nur an sich und an
ihresgleichen
sie häufen nur an ich kenne keinen
präsidenten keinen bürgermeister oder
ein regierungsmitglied dass die armut
kennt
kritik an der politik ja aber wenn es um
die kartelle geht verstummen josé und
all die anderen keinem in die quere
kommen bloß nicht auffallen das ist
mexiko
wir müssen uns einen ort vorstellen an
dem die menschen sehr wenig geld haben
da kommen plötzlich bewaffnet und bieten
care pakete an
nein zu sagen kann einen bereits haben
oder auch nicht aber das zu riskieren
ist zu viel
diese menschen melden wem denn kein
vertrauen in den staat das gefühl
alleine gelassen zu werden
davon erzählt auch natalie o
schritt für schritt versuchen wir voran
zu kommen wenn du nicht für dich selbst
kämpft macht es auch sonst keiner für
dich wir sind ein land in dem in der
vergangenheit nur einige wenige
profitiert haben vor allem
geschäftsleute und politische gruppen
sie haben in einer gesellschaft die nach
und nach immer mehr in armut zerfiel
ihre wohltätigkeit nur vorgetäuscht oder
sie nur zu wahl zwecken genutzt
auch alessandra wird in ihrer arbeit
täglich damit konfrontiert mit armut
gewalt hoffnungslosigkeit
es herrscht ein gefühl der
ungerechtigkeit wenn man hier solch
große probleme hat aber keine
unterstützung erfährt
als wir nach den lebensmittelspenden der
kartelle fragen wird sie vorsichtig sehr
vorsichtig weil sie weiß dass es auch
hier im viertel mittelsmänner gibt cool
dass sie helfen wollen aber wenn sie die
gesellschaft wirklich unterstützen
wollten dann müssten sie aufhören mit
ihren geschäften dinge zu ändern zu
legalisieren ihre die wirkliche hilfe
daran glauben kann alexandra so recht
nicht die kartelle gehören zur realität
und auf veränderungen darauf hoffen sie
in mexiko seit jahrzehnten
[Musik]